Las Vegas's biggest convention returns
today in fact attendance numbers at CES
expected to be back to pre-pandemic
levels so that is the good news joining
me now lifestyle experts so excited to
have Chris and Wessel joining us now
you've got four gadgets we've got three
minutes it's like The Price is Right
what do you got for us let's get going
thank you so much for having me CES is
such a great great show and first we
have pixie pixie is an AI smart baby
camera that offers numerous features to
make parenting so much easier the
covered face detection alerts parents
when something is covering the baby's
face and there is an area detection that
allows for a very safe Zone to know when
their child is moving in and out of it
it's so smart there's also a temperature
and humidity detection ensuring that the
room isn't too hot or too cold in the
smart music box automatically detects
cries and plays calming sounds it also
get this captures images so parents can
create a visual diary to look back on
all of the memories all those precious
memories you know they may not be in the
room for oh that's fantastic and we
forget right so it's nice that they grab
that exactly pixie okay awesome cool
stuff yeah so that's for the parents and
the little ones and and you got one that
that could work for all of us here too
exactly next we have the uh
self-dispensing refillable electronic
toothbrush this was designed with
accessibility in mind for elderly and
disabled people once it's filled with
toothpaste only one hand is needed this
is called flick Nest self dispensary so
this is so great for oral hygiene the
toothbrush is a must-have for those who
wear aligners or braces because it has
toothpaste inside of it also has a Sleek
design and easy to use during the day
perfect oh it isn't sanitizing there too
uh yes I love that because I always
worry about my toothbrush especially you
know after you've been sick you want to
sanitize it okay that's awesome what
else that is nest and then we have flick
this is amazing flick twist is the first
Wireless dial for your smart home so you
can put everything all in one full smart
home control under one device you can
control the lights the music and more
without any voice commands or any apps
the flick button allows you to control
anything with just a push and it's a
small wireless button that is easy to
set up it replaces all the apps and
other voice coming out I love it yes
make it easier for me please there's too
many out there Kristen we only need one
device one device now finally okay we
got one minute left so let's bring in
our other guests here with this
incredible bike what is this well this
is a very new uh bike that we've
developed and it's not based on
flywheels because they've been around
for 100 years yeah they don't really
work that well so we put in a robot a
very strong motor and AI to measure what
you're doing and to give you back
exactly the forces that you feel while
you're cycling wow and what that does it
doesn't give you just a cardio that you
get in a spinning bike but it also gives
you real strength development like you
get outdoors and as we know now muscle
development is so important to stay
healthy right right now but also health
age much healthier so and the other cool
things that this thing does because it's
robotics we can Harvest your energy
because it's a motor we harvest the
energy that you're using and as you can
see it the bike is running without any
uh power outlet wow that is fantastic
and it's also connected to the internet
so everything is uploaded right away and
you have the screen it gives you all the
information it's Health it's healthy
it's watching kids it's everything CES
is so cool I wish we could spend hours
learning about this I love this bike I'm
going to ask more about this in the
break uh guys thank you so much for
being here today we appreciate you good
luck at CES it's